[Música]
en la región boliviana de Santa Cruz al
menos una persona murió hoy durante las
protestas que piden un nuevo censo con
el fin de equilibrar los desajustes de
recursos y representación política en el
parlamento
a una semana de la segunda vuelta
electoral en Brasil el presidente Yair
bolsonaro Busca cerrar la diferencia que
según las encuestas le saca alucinación
Lula da Silva algunos simpatizantes de
izquierda buscan en él una alternativa a
la corrupción asociada al anterior
gobierno de Lula
el anuncio de Estados Unidos de recibir
tan solo a 24.000 migrantes venezolanos
se ha llevado a muchos de ellos a buscar
alternativas algunos pedirán asilo en
México o intentarán migrar a otro estado
suramericano
bienvenido a este nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano
abrimos esta emisión en Bolivia al menos
una persona murió en la ciudad de Santa
Cruz en el inicio de una huelga que
demanda un nuevo censo los manifestantes
aseguran que su región está recibiendo
menos recursos y menor representación en
el parlamento debido a los datos
desactualizados el movimiento ha
desembocado en enfrentamientos violentos
con el oficialismo el informes de Manuel
acano
una aparente tranquilidad se respira en
Santa Cruz calles vacías y bloqueos con
neumáticos marcan el panorama de la
ciudad boliviana luego de que choques
entre opositores y oficialistas esta
mañana se dieran al inicio de la huelga
en la región los manifestantes que se
tomaron las calles exigen un nuevo censo
Con urgencia de hoy empezó un paro
Cívico
con bloqueos
exigiendo que se realice en Bolivia un
censo en el primer semestre del 2023
mayores recursos y escaños en el
parlamento del país son dos de las
razones por las cuales los manifestantes
demandan un censo y aseguran que la
región la más poblada del país se está
viendo afectada por datos
desactualizados
nosotros necesitamos más recursos esta
este departamento Santa Cruz es muy
grande y en los recursos están muy
limitados para la salud la educación la
huelga ha dividido opiniones dentro de
la población expresadas de manera
violenta y tanto la ONU como la Unión
Europea han condenado los hechos
ONU Bolivia lamenta la pérdida de una
vida humana y exhorta a los actores
políticos y sociales a evitar escenarios
de confrontación y violencia que pongan
en riesgo el orden público y la vida de
las personas el gobierno de de Luis Arce
ha asegurado que el censo solo podrá
realizarse en 2024
la división que vivió Bolivia revive los
temores de la violencia política de 2019
cuando opositores de derecha denunciaron
un fraude en las elecciones de ese año y
acusaron como responsable a la
izquierdista Evo Morales quien renunció
en medio de la crisis
y seguimos con nuestro cubrimiento
especial en France 24 de la campaña para
la segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales en Brasil la puesta del
mandatario Yair bolsonaro por la
reelección ha encontrado inesperados
aliados simpatizantes de la izquierda
conquistados por las ayudas sociales o
por el temor a la corrupción que el
presidente ha asociado con su rival
luicinacio Lula da Silva por estas dos
vías ha ganado apoyos que pueden ser
decisivos en el balotaje del 30 de
octubre
afuera del centro de bienestar de este
suburbio obrero de Río familias enteras
hacen cola algunos incluso han dormido
aquí con la esperanza de recibir por fin
El auxilio Brasil el beneficio social
creado bajo el gobierno de bolsonaro que
acaba de ser en casi 40 dólares justo
antes de las elecciones
desempleados y residenciados en la
vecina Favela de marea yoyanny elly y
Johnny Siempre han votado por la
izquierda Pero esta vez el presidente y
sus valores profamilia han ganado su
voto
tengo un hijo de 4 años y estoy
embarazada no tengo trabajo así que esta
ayuda es muy valiosa para mí para
pagarme alquiler mis compras mis
medicamentos también recibimos un cupón
para ayudar a comprar gasolina
quien te ayuda te bendice y para mí ya
ir bolsonaro es una bendición soy
cristiana y votaré por él porque ha
demostrado que apoya a las familias
aunque no esté de acuerdo con todo lo
que dice está del lado de la familia
Jair bolsonaro no solo Ha logrado ganar
nuevos votantes en los barrios pobres
que solían ser bastión de la izquierda
sino que también la conquistado muchos
pueblos pequeños y rurales
en el estado de ríos San José prietos la
localidad que más voto a favor del
presidente y candidato en la primera
vuelta su apoyo ha crecido En
comparación con 2018 la mayoría de los
residentes son cristianos evangélicos
como él pero no es la única razón gran
defensor de los terratenientes
bolsionaron supo complacer a estos
pequeños productores en medio de la
escasez trayendo fertilizantes desde
Rusia
desde nuestro punto de vista Esperamos
que obtenga más fertilizantes y
productos del exterior para ayudarnos a
los productores pero también para ayudar
a la economía de Brasil como lo hizo al
bajar el precio de la gasolina que se
disparó y nos afectó mucho
Parece ser más sincero Aunque coincido
en que se equivocó durante la pandemia
se retrasó en la compra de vacunas y
mucha gente murió por eso creo que será
una mejor opción que Lula para mí
Estos son votantes conservadores
moderados con una cosa en común el miedo
a que regresen al poder Lula y la
izquierda a quienes consideran corruptos
tras el anuncio el 12 de octubre por
parte de Estados Unidos que acogería un
máximo de 24.000 venezolanos llegando
por su frontera aérea y que deportaría a
quienes accedieran por la frontera
mexicana muchos migrantes se encontraron
bloqueados en México algunos pedirán
asilo en este país o intentarán migrar a
otro estado suramericano Gabriel colchén
nos cuenta más
y su familia cambiaron su país de
destino en vez de ir a Estados Unidos se
dirigen hacia Costa Rica
ya de volvernos a o unos que pidieron
asilo aquí en México y otros que que
continuó que vamos a continuar a Costa
Rica
Venezuela Cuándo viene usted hermosa
casi dos meses viajando porque fuimos
caminando otros como Juan Manuel
decidieron irse a Panamá yo no lo había
como un sueño
[Música]
pero ya como tanto inconveniente para
seguir avanzando sin arrepentimiento
para atrás el gobierno anunció el 12 de
octubre que solo acordará la entrada
legal a 24.000 venezolanos llegando por
vía aérea y que deportará a todos los
que están intentando cruzar la frontera
ilegalmente por vía terrestre ahora
miles de inmigrantes venezolanos se
encuentran en la incertidumbre muchas
familias que habían empezado el viaje
hace semanas están bloqueadas en México
porque uno gastó todos los ahorros que
tenía nosotros tenemos pasando un mes y
medio viajando y lo que teníamos ya ya
se ha gastado ya ya lo que queda es poco
y uno se va para allá entonces lo
devuelve entonces
perdemos el pasaje perdemos todo las
fuerzas de seguridad guatemaltecas y
mexicanas organizaron un despliegue
militar en el puente del río Suchiate
que separa los dos países se preparan
para frenar el el flujo de inmigrantes
que intentan llegar a México ayer Andrés
Manuel López Obrador el presidente de
México instó a Caracas y Washington el
retomar el diálogo para encontrar una
solución pronta el número de venezolanos
que buscan llegar a Estados Unidos se ha
disparado este año en medio de la
inclusión de la economía de su país
entre octubre de 2021 y agosto de este
año más de 150.000 venezolanos entraron
a Estados Unidos por México en Colombia
miles de personas se manifestaron el
sábado en varias ciudades del país en
marchas organizadas por una plataforma
ciudadana opositora al gobierno de
Gustavo Petro la protesta iba dirigida
contra la reforma fiscal en medio de una
fuerte devaluación de la moneda
enmarcada en un contexto global
inflacionario según los organizadores se
protestó también contra las reformas a
las pensiones y a la salud así como a la
política de la paz total en el marco del
conflicto armado
y cerramos este informativo con noticias
deportivas la selección femenina Sub 17
de Colombia ha conseguido clasificar
para la semifinal de la copa del mundo
que tiene lugar en India para ampliar la
noticia contamos en nuestro estudio con
nuestro periodismo con nuestro
periodista deportivo Luis Méndez Luis
porque es tan importante esta victoria
de la selección femenina colombiana
Rodrigo es importante esta Victoria por
dos razones en primer lugar porque es un
torneo que ha sido ganado por países
asiáticos y europeos a lo largo de toda
su historia Colombia con esta llegada a
la semifinal sería la tercera nación
latinoamericana que accede a esta
instancia luego de lo hecho por
Venezuela que lo hizo en par de
ocasiones y México que quedó su campeona
Hace cuatro años para el fútbol
colombiano el resultado también es
gratamente positivo porque se presenta
luego de cuatro participaciones en copas
del mundo de este tipo en las que nunca
habían podido pasar de la primera ronda
y solamente había obtenido una sola
Victoria en un partido además
en pleno auge del fútbol femenino en el
país que logró el subcampeonato en la
pasada edición de la Copa América a
pesar del poco apoyo que tienen por
parte de las autoridades del fútbol
colombiano por otro lado no hay que
dejar de lado que una jugadora de este
equipo y que ya formó parte de la
selección femenina de mayores como lo es
linda Caicedo está nominada a la mejor
jugadora de año un premio que entrega
global Soccer Awards pues Luis Muchas
gracias por ampliarnos esta noticia con
ella llegamos al final de este
informativo sigan conectados a Franz 24
y France 24.com
[Música]